-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy you're here.
I love you.
Guys, Halloween is right
around the corner.
I'm excited about this,
but listen to this.
A new report found that a bunch
of chocolate products
contain a concerning amount of
lead and other heavy metals.
In response, Hershey's put out
a statement that said,
"You're supposed to take
the tin foil off, you morons."
[ Laughter ]
Unwrap it.
Of course, everyone's decorating
their houses for Halloween,
and this year it seems like a
lot of people had the same idea.
Watch this.
-Taylor Swift mania
is taking over Halloween.
-One Wisconsin woman
put this Eras Tour-themed
decor up in her front yard.
-Swifties are sure
to be enchanted
by this haunting sight.
-A certain skeletal
football player
in awe of an uncanny pop star.
-In Indiana,
Swift-themed
Halloween decorations.
-All the decorations
are Taylor Swift.
-This is Taylor Swift-kin,
a nearly 400-pound pumpkin
dedicated to Taylor Swift.
-Taylor was like,
"Thank you for all the tributes
and that one horrendous insult."
Yikes.
Yep, Halloween is almost here,
which means there are
pumpkin products everywhere.
Starbucks, Oreos, Wendy's, Ihop.
Everyone's getting in on it.
And maybe nowhere
more than Trader Joe's.
They go nuts for pumpkin.
In fact, check out this ad
I just saw.
-Hey, pumpkin lovers,
Trader Joe's
is your one-stop-shop
for pumpkin this fall.
Our fan-favorite
pumpkin bread mix is back!
Plus we've got pumpkin scones,
pumpkin bagels,
pumpkin brioche toast,
pumpkin cheesecake,
pumpkin yogurt,
and even pumpkin soap.
[ Chuckles ]
Throw it all
in your pumpkin cart
and pay at our pumpkin register
with our pumpkin employees
to feed your pumpkin wife and
pumpkin kids and pumpkin dog.
[ Dog barks ]
Don't forget to bring
your tote bag!
Trader Joe's --
we've got pumpkins!
-Oh! [ Chuckles ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's nice.
It's a little scary, right?
Well, switching gears
to some political news,
the House finally
elected a speaker.
His name is Mike Johnson,
and most people
don't really know who he is.
So if you're not familiar,
here's a picture of him.
I'm sorry.
That -- That's not Mike Johnson.
That's Mike Flood.
He's also a congressman,
but he's not the new speaker.
This is Mike Johnson.
Wait, no, sorry.
That's -- That's Mike Turner.
That's Mike Turner.
That's Mike Carey.
That's Mike Kelly.
That's Mike Gallagher.
That's Mike Pence.
That's Mike Tyson.
That's Mike Myers.
That's also Mike Myers.
Mike Myers.
Michael Myers.
That's Mike Wazowski.
Oh, come on! The speaker's
name is Mike Johnson!
-Yeah.
-No. That's Magic...Johnson.
That's Magic Mike.
That's Randy Johnson.
That's
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson.
That's a bad wax statue
of Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson.
That's a bottle
of Johnson & Johnson.
Scarlett Johansson.
That's Lil Jon-son.
Why is this so hard?
He's our speaker of the House.
We should know who he is.
His name is Mike Johnson!
No, that's Mick Jagger!
Will someone please just get the
right picture of Mike Johnson?
There we go. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Was that so hard?
Meanwhile, earlier today,
Mike Johnson met
with President Biden
for the first time
since becoming speaker.
Johnson is pretty famous
for being an election denier,
so it got pretty awkward
when he said,
"Good to meet you,
'President' Biden."
But the meeting
was very friendly.
Biden even invited Johnson
to pet his dog.
[ Laughter ]
And this was nice.
Biden told a story
about his days in Congress,
and by the time it was over,
Johnson was already
voted out as speaker.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this
today in Phoenix?
Uber started offering
driverless rides.
Even worse, the driver
is still there just to chat.
[ Laughter ]
Lyft also has a version
of driverless rides,
but they just put a cinder
block on the gas pedal.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news.
I saw that Domino's
is giving away
$1 million worth of free pizzas
to customers
with student loan payments.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Customers are like, "Okay,
but what if you gave us
$1 million worth of dollars?"
[ Laughter ]
Guys, Britney Spears's
new memoir is out,
and people were surprised
to hear
that she has Michelle Williams
to do the audio book.
I'm not sure why
everyone's so surprised.
Celebrities reading
other celebrities' audio books
is actually pretty common.
I mean, for example,
John Travolta
narrated Prince Harry's
book "Spare."
-Did he really?
-Yeah.
-[ As Travolta ]
Upon arriving home,
I'd been horrified
to discover
that my nether regions
was frost-nipped as well,
and while the ears
and the cheeks
were already healing,
the todger wasn't."
[ Chuckles ]
[ Applause ]
-I mean...
-I didn't know that.
-Yeah. Jerry Seinfeld narrated
Elton John's book, "Me."
-[ As Seinfeld ]
I've played pianos,
I've jumped on pianos,
I've fallen off pianos,
I've pushed a piano
into the crowd!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You didn't know that?
Yeah.
Adam Sandler narrated
Matthew McConaughey's book
"Greenlights."
-[ As Sandler ] There is nothing
wrong with smoking
a little fun stuff
and playing your drums naked
at night in your own home;
who do they think they are
comin' in your house like that?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, these are --
these are great audio books.
-Oh. On Audible.
-Barry -- Barry Gibb narrated
Stanley Tucci's book "Taste."
-[ As Gibb ] To me,
eating well is not just about
what tastes good
but about the connections
that are made through
the food itself.
-Yeah, it's a great --
It's fantastic. Listen.
And finally,
this might surprise you,
but Al Pacino did
the narration for my book,
"Your Baby's First Word
Will Be Dada."
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-[ As Pacino ] Dada!
Moo!
Dada!
Baa!
Quack!
Dada!
Hoooah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's just -- It's fun. Anyways,
the holidays are coming up.
[ Chuckles ]
-Wow!
Wow.
-[ Laughs ]
-Guys, get this.
Mattel just reported
a massive jump in sales
thanks to the Barbie movie.
Yeah.
Unfortunately, Hasbro's sales
of "Oppenheimer" toys
have been really disappointing.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys, I read that
Beyoncé just launched
a new perfume called Cé Noir.
It's pretty cool.
Well, it turns out Cé Noir
isn't the only new fragrance
on the market.
A lot of people, even companies,
have released new fragrances
in time for the holidays.
I'll show you what I mean.
For instance,
President Biden
has a new cologne.
It's called...
[whispering] Malarkáy.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
The NFL also launched
their own fragrance...
[whispering] Obsession...
With Taylor Swift.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Similarly, Ticketmaster
just released a new fragrance...
[whispering] Bleu It.
[ Laughter, applause ]
New speaker of the House
Mike Johnson
even released his own cologne...
[whispering] Choice No. 5.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert
just released her new perfume...
[whispering] Beetle J'uice.
[ Laughter ]
And now Congressman
George Santos
has launched a new fragrance...
[whispering] L'Bullsheé.
[ Laughter, applause ]
And finally, Donald Trump
just released his new scent...
[whispering] Golden Toilette.
[ Laughter ]
Well, good luck to all of them
this holiday season.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well...
finally, I heard about a man
in New York City
who was freed after
being locked overnight
in the safe room
of a jewelry store.
The guy was like,
"Hey, I'm not going to sue.
And with that being said,
please don't check
my stool tomorrow morning."